THE MORNING WE WILL START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE AND- THANK YOU I
STILL KNOW HOW TO USE TECHNOLOGY
FROM LIKE NINETEEN TEN- AND IF
OUR MEMBERS ARE WATCHING OR
STABS IF YOU COULD HAVE YOUR
FOLKS COME TO REESTABLISH A
QUORUM THAT BE GREAT WE'RE CLOSE
BUT NOT QUITE THERE YET. WELCOME
TO THE ASSEMBLY. WE'RE ASKING
AUTHORS TO GIVE SUCCINCT
PRESENTATIONS EACH BILL KIND OF
TO ME WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION EACH MAIN ONE IS WILL
GET YOU MINUTES EACH. WE
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE PRIMARY
WITNESSES TO APPEAR IN PERSON
BUT WE'LL MAKE EXCEPTIONS ON A
CASE BY CASE BASIS. PLEASE BE
ADVISED THAT FOR ALL OTHER
WITNESSES CALLING IN TO REGISTER
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION ON BILLS
TO ASK THAT YOU. ONLY SAY YOUR
NAME ORGANIZATION AND POSITION
ON THE BILL. IF YOU SAY MORE THE
OPERATOR WILL CUT YOU OFF IF YOU
ARE UNABLE TO GET THROUGH ON THE
PHONE WITH THE FREE TO SUBMIT
WRITTEN TEST. WE FOR THE PORT ON
THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE THIS
WILL BECOME PART OF THE OFFICIAL
RECORD OF THE BILL. THE CALL
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE ONE
TWO SIX. YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS
NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON YOUR TV
SCREEN. IF YOU ARE CALLING IN
PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO IS THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL YOUR
TESTIFYING ON. IS BEGINNING
THEIR BILL PRESENTATION. THE
OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL GIVE
YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN QUEUE BASED ON WHETHER
YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE THE BILL.
IF YOU'RE CALLING IN PLACE
ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND NOISE
THIS INCLUDES MEETING OR LIVE
STREAM BROADCAST AND YOUR SMART
DEVICES TO REDUCE IT. DISTORTION
ADVISES THAT IF YOU ARE A MAIN
WITNESS PROVIDING TESTIMONY FOR
AGAINST A BILL YOU'LL- YOU'LL
REMAIN ON A LIFELINE AND WILL
NEED TO MUTE YOURSELF UNTIL YOU
ARE CALLED TO SPEAK. I ALSO
WANNA NOTE WE ARE ACCEPTING
WRITTEN TESTIMONY TO THE
POSITION LETTER PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. WE NEED TO
LIMIT HOW LONG THE PHONE LINES
ARE OPEN FOR EACH BILL AS WE ARE
IN A TIGHT HEARING SCHEDULE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
UNDERSTANDING. AND WITH THAT WE
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH REQUIREMENTS
WILL START AS SUBCOMMITTEE AND-
SENATOR WIENER YOU ARE FIRST.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
THEIR- I AM I HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF MY JOIN AUTHOR- CENTER
ALAN T PRESENT- SENATE
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT TO
WHICH FULL REPEAL ARTICLE THIRTY
FOUR OF THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION- SCO TO PASSED THE
SENATE ON A THIRTY SEVEN NOTHING
BIPARTISAN VOTE- IT ALSO-
RECEIVE THE SAME- OVERWHELMING
VOTE A COUPLE YEARS AGO- ARTICLE
THIRTY FOUR- IS FRANKLY A SCAR
ON CALIFORNIA'S CONSTITUTION IT
WAS PASSED IN NINETEEN FIFTY.
OUR AND REACTION TO- EFFORTS TO
BUILD MORE ON PUBLICLY FUNDED
HOUSING FOR LOW INCOME PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA- ARTICLE THIRTY FOUR-
SINGLES OUT PUBLICLY FUNDED. LOW
INCOME HOUSING FOR- TREATMENT-
THAT IS NOT APPLY TO ANY OTHER
FORM OF HOUSING SPECIFICALLY
THAT IT CAN ONLY BE APPROVED BY
THE VOTERS NOT BY CITY COUNCIL.
NOT BY COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS- NOT BY PLANNING
COMMISSION ONLY BY THE VOTERS NO
UP FORM A OF HOUSING PROJECTED
ONTO THIS APPROVAL REQUIREMENT.
ARTICLE THIRTY FOUR WAS. PLACED
ON THE BALLOT AND PASSED IN A
FAIRLY UGLY PERIOD IN
CALIFORNIA- HISTORY WERE PEOPLE
WERE FIGHTING AGAINST ANY EFFORT
ON TO HAVE PEOPLE OF COLOR LOW
INCOME PEOPLE LIVING IN CERTAIN
NEIGHBOURHOODS AND WAS DESIGNED
AS A WAY TO BE ABLE TO STOP-
THAT- KIND OF HOUSING. AND OVER
THE YEARS IT HAS HAD THE IMPACT
OF SLOWING DOWN AND STOPPING THE
KIND OF HOUSING CALIFORNIA LOST
OUT REFUSE AMOUNT OF FEDERAL
FUNDING FOR PUBLIC HOUSING BACK
WHEN THE GOVERNMENT WAS IN THE
BIT OF ACTUALLY FUND HOUSE. IN
IT'S- DO NOT GO FORWARD BECAUSE
OF ARTICLE THIRTY FOUR WHERE IT
TAKES TIME OR THEY HAVE TO PAY
FOR CAMPAIGN- TO PASSAGE OF THE
BALLOT AND SO IT MAKES THIS KIND
OF HOUSING- TAKE LONGER AND BE
MORE EXPENSIVE WE NEED TO BE
VERY CLEAR THAT THIS KIND OF
HOUSING PUBLICLY FUNDED HOUSING
FOR LOW INCOME WORKING CLASS
PEOPLE IS EXACTLY THE KIND OF
HOUSING WHAT WE NW CALL SOCIAL
HOUSING THANK YOU THE CHAIR INTO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEAVE FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON SOCIAL HOUSING.
EXACTLY THE KIND OF HOUSING THAT
WE NEED TO ADDRESS OUR
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS- THIS IS THE
KIND OF HOUSING THAT WILL MEAN
THAT ONE LOW INCOME RENTERS ARE
EVICTED THAT THEY DON'T
AUTOMATICALLY ARE ALMOST
AUTOMATICALLY WIND UP ON THE
STREETS- IT'S A WAY TO
STABILIZE- OUR COMMUNITIES AND
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE- THAT IT IS
A TOOL IN A TOOL KIT- IT'S TIME
FOR OUR REPORT TO GO AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. I WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF A TWO IS CAPITAL
LEWIS THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE SACRAMENTO HOUSING ALLIANCE
. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR KNOW WHAT I'M SORRY I WANT
TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM REAL
QUICK. LET'S TAKE ROLE APOLOGIES
. WICKS HERE HERE. THEY ARE TO
HEAR CARILLO AFTER YOU HEAR
GABRIEL KALRA KALRA HERE KILEY
BENNETT BENNETT HERE LEE. LEE
HERE. HARM OKAY WE HAVE A QUORUM
MAYBE IN. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS- THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY AGAIN
MY NAME IS KENDRA LEWIS AND I AM
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
SACRAMENTO HOUSING ALLIANCE- AND
TO JUST FURTHER STATE THAT THE
ARTICLE THIRTY FOUR WAS PASSED
BY VOTERS- IN NINETEEN FIFTY
DURING AN OVERTLY RACIST
CAMPAIGN THAT. PANDER TO HARMFUL
IN BASIS STEREOTYPES ABOUT BLACK
BROWN AND INDIGENOUS POPULATION
I SPOKE AND I COME TO YOU ALSO
SPEAKING FROM EXPERIENCE MY
GRANDPARENTS EMIGRATED FROM THE
JIM CROW SOUTH AND- LIVED IN
BAYVIEW HUNTERS POINT
NEIGHBORHOOD THAT WAS REDLINED
AT THE TIME AND HAS AS SENSE
REALLY EXPERIENCE SO ARTICLE
THIRTY FOUR AS WELL AS OTHER
NEIGHBORHOODS THROUGHOUT OUR
STATE. THEN THE MEASURE HAS
ALLOWED COMMUNITIES TO AVOID
RACIAL INTEGRATION AND REJECTED
PEOPLE WITH LOW INCOMES BY
BLOCKING DEVELOPMENT DESPITE THE
POSITIVE DEMOCRATIC APPEAL THE
REQUIREMENTS OF VOTER APPROVAL
FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF
SUBSIDIZED HOUSING CREATES AND
PERPETUATES RACIALLY AND
ECONOMICALLY HOMOGENEOUS
COMMUNITIES AND FLIES IN THE
FACE OF THE STATE'S LONGSTANDING
FAIR SHARE HOUSING REQUIREMENTS
AND THE OBLIGATION OF ALL LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS UNDER BOTH STATE AND
FEDERAL LAW TO AFFIRM IT
AFFIRMATIVELY FURTHER FAIR
HOUSING. IN ADDITION TO THIS
DISCRIMINATORY DISCRIMINATORY
IMPACT ARTICLE THIRTY FOUR ADS.
POSSIBLE LOCAL. BUDGETS TO
CONDUCT PERIODIC PERIODIC
ARTICLE THIRTY FOUR ELECTIONS
AND TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECTS I'M SORRY AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PROJECTS IN THE FORM OF
LEAD. JERRY TO DEMONSTRATE THE-
THAT THE PROJECT IS ARTICLE
THIRTY FOUR COMPLIANT BASICALLY
ARE AFFORDABLE HOUSING BUILDERS
HAVE SO MANY HURDLES AND
OFTENTIMES PROJECTS- THAT SHOULD
BE GOING FORWARD DO NOT THERE
ENOUGH HURDLES TO PRODUCING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR THE LACK
OF SUFFICIENT FINANCING STIFF
COMPETITION FOR MARKET RATE
DEVELOPERS FOR DEVON DESIRABLE
SITES. TO OPPOSITION TO INCREASE
DENSITY IT MAKES NO SENSE TO
CONTINUE TO MAINTAIN ARTICLE
THIRTIES FULL ARTICLE THIRTY
FOURS ADDITIONAL CHALLENGE OF
VOTER APPROVAL FOR PUBLICLY SENT
TO SUBSIDIZE HOUSING IN THE
FACES OF OUR DIRE NEED FOR MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS IN OUR
STATE THIS IS DEEPLY PROBLEMATIC
REQUIREMENT AND HAS NO PLACE IN
THE LAWS OF OUR GREAT STATE IT
IS LONG PAST TIME FOR TO BE
REPEALED WE STRONGLY SUPPORT WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT. THE A TO AN
URGENT YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND- WHETHER ANY OTHER PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OKAY WILL
BRING IT TO THE- FROOME HERE
OTHER FOLKS IN SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING ON A LAWLER ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION AND THE
PUBLIC INTEREST LAW PROJECT IN
SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING JENNIFER
AMENTO WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING CONSORTIUM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. MORNING
MARKETS ALL THE ON BEHALF OF
HOUSING CALIFORNIA AND STRONG
SUPPORT. MANJERI MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS DURING KIND OF
COVER ALL I'M HAVE A TOUGH FOR
YOU TO BE IN SUPPORT. MARINO
WIND HERE FOR MARK SAVERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP
IN SUPPORT. GREAT WE WILL NOW
OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES OPERATOR
IF YOU COULD Q. PEOPLE UP WHO
WANT TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR- SCA. TO THANK YOU IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. WILL FIRST GO TO LINE
NUMBER TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
NICOLO DELUCA CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE NONPROFIT HOUSING
ASSOCIATION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT AND
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND LINE
NUMBER THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
AREN'T ABLE AND FAIR
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION FOR. THANK
YOU LINE NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
SURE REPORT WITH THE CORPORATION
FOR SUPPORTIVE HOUSING IN STRONG
SUPPORT. LINE NUMBER. THIRTY
NINE. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS COULD I FEEL LIKE I
FEEL CRANK CALLING ON BEHALF OF
ALL HOLDEN AND AT THE AT HOME IN
STRONG SUPPORT. MY NUMBER FORTY
. BUT I'M SURE THIS IS BOB NEAL
REPRESENTING FIELD SAID IN
COMPANY THAT'S OWNED BY HOWARD
AHMANSON JUNIOR IN ORANGE COUNTY
PHILANTHROPISTS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU LINE NUMBER
THIRTY SEVEN. LINE THIRTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SCINTIGRAPHY
ON BEHALF OF WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY PRONTO SPONSOR
IN STRONG SUPPORT. MY NUMBER
FORTY TWO. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS THIS IS THE SAND
OF ALL WITH PATH PEOPLE
ASSISTING THE HOMELESS
ENTHUSIASTIC SUPPORT. WHY NUMBER
TWENTY NINE. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THAT REFORM
ON BEHALF OF LA FAMILY HOUSING
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT AT C.
A. TWO THANK YOU. MY NUMBER
FORTY FIVE. HELLO MY NAME IS
BRIAN PRESS GOOD ALLING FOR LOS
ANGELES CALIFORNIA AND THE
NUMBER OF ABUNDANT HOUSING LA
AND WOULD SPEAK IN SUPPORT. LINE
AT THIRTY FOUR. MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS STILL BE AT THE LEAST
SHOP ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES THE CITY OF SANTA
MONICA AND CITY AND COUNTY OF
SAN FRANCISCO MARYLAND.
GREAT LET'S BRING IT- BACK TO
THE ROOM HEARD WE HAVE PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. OKAY
ANYONE IN THE ROOM WHICH TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION. AN OPERATOR
IF THERE ARE ANY FOLKS WHO WISH
TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE PLEASE QUEUE THEM UP. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE.
SORRY OPERATOR IS THERE ANYONE.
THE WANT TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. OKAY I THINK EVERYONE WAS
SPEAKING OPPOSITION I WILL BRING
IT BACK HERE TO THE COMMITTEE MR
COLOR. THANK YOU- THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- AND I WANT TO
THANK- THE AUTHORS- FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD FOR TAKING-
ANOTHER SHOT OF THIS I KNOW IT'S
BEEN ATTEMPTED BEFORE BUT I FEEL
VERY HOPEFUL- THAT- IF WE BRING
THIS- BEFORE THE ELECTORATE
TODAY- THAT WE CAN GET THIS
PASSED AT THIS THE JUST THING TO
DO IS THE RIGHT THING TO DO IT
REALLY IS ONE OF THE MANY
DIFFERENT- THINGS WE HAVE ON THE
BOOKS THAT LINK US TO- ARE
PASSED IN A IN A WAY THAT- THAT
THERE'S BEEN NOT JUST RACIALLY
DISCRIMINATORY BUT IS AS TORN
APART. IN MANY WAYS WHEN ABOUT
TORN APART NEIGHBORHOODS CABINET
WAS DIVIDED- IT IS BUT-
PREVENTED IT IT ALSO THE ABILITY
FOR MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY
GAME GENERATIONAL WEALTH AND SO-
I'M VERY HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT
WOULD LEAD TO BE JOINED AS A CO
AUTHOR- IF POSSIBLE AND. HAPPY
TO MAKE MOTION. TO THE BILL.
SEVEN SECOND I KNOW MR LEE
WANTED TO SAY SOMETHING AS WELL
. YES JUST WANNA THANK CENTER AL
CENTER OF COURSE ARE SEVERE THIS
EFFORT AGAIN. IN OUR FIGHT
AGAINST HOUSING CRISIS WE NEED
TO HAVE ALL OPTIONS ON THE TABLE
AND CLEARING THE WAY FOR
PUBLICLY EVELOPED HOUSING.
ESPECIALLY FOR WORKING CLASS
FAMILIES IS SO IMPORTANT SO WE
NEED HAVE ALL OPTIONS ON TABLE
AND IF POSSIBLE AS WELL WOULD
LOVE TO BE AS CO AUTHOR BUT I
THINK THIS IS A COMMON SENSE
MEASURE. AND I HOPE EVERYONE
WILL BE- IN THE FIGHT TO PASS
THIS ON THE BALLOT AS WELL SO.
HAPPY SUPPORT COURSE. GREAT ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS WE HAVE A MOTION
SECONDS- WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
WEST GRANADA GREAT THANK YOU AND
JUST- ALSO THANK YOU AND SENATOR
ALAN AS WELL IF YOUR GREAT WORK
ON THIS I'D LIKE TO BE ADDED AS
A CO AUTHOR AS WELL AND LOOK FOR
TO MOVING THE SPLIT OF
COMMITTEES TODAY. MOTIONED ARE A
BIT UP FIFTEEN REFER TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN APPROPRIATIONS
WICKS FIVE WEEKS I'D SAY
OCTOBER. IS HEREBY CARILLO.
KURAI GABRIEL. KALRA KALRA AYE
KILEY KILEY AYE BENNETT. LI LI I. IN NINETEEN THIRTY FIVE HI.
THAT BILLS OUT BUT WE'LL LEAVE
IT OPEN THANK YOU. YEAH.
I NEXT UP WE HAVE A CA FOURTEEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS MADAM
CHAIR WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- MEMBERS. THIS COMMITTEE HAS WORKED
EXTENSIVELY THIS YEAR AND IN
PAST YEARS ON AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND ON THE HOMELESSNESS CRISIS
WE HAVE PASSED SIXTY FIVE BILLS
OUT OF COMMITTEE JUST THIS YEAR
AND ARE TAKING ON DIFFERENT
ASPECTS OF THE HOUSING CRISIS
AND YOU'LL NOTICE YOU'VE GONE
THROUGH THESE VERY LONG
COMMITTEE HEARING HEARINGS THAT
WE'VE HAD WE'VE PASSED
LEGISLATION TO ADDRESS THE ACK
OF AVAILABLE LAND FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IN THE NEED FOR A LARGER
WORK FORCE TO BUILD HOUSING.
THIS MEASURE RESPONSE TO A
DIFFERENT ISSUE. THE LACK OF
ADEQUATE AN ONGOING FUNDING FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS. THE STATE'S LACK
OF SIGNIFICANT ONGOING
INVESTMENTS IN NEW AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. AND IN OUR HOMELESSNESS
RESPONSE SYSTEM HAS LED US TO
THIS HOUSING AFFORDABILITY
CRISIS. THE ONLY WAY OUT OF THIS
IS TO BUILD MORE UNITS. THE
SPREAD OUT NATURE OF THE STATE'S
INVESTMENT IS LEFT US IN NEED OF
AT LEAST ONE MILLION NEW UNITS
TO MEET THE NEEDS OF OUR LOWER
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS. BETWEEN TWO
THOUSAND AND TWELVE AND TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE STATE'S IN
THE STATE INVESTED LESS THAN
THREE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR IN CREATING A NEW
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS. AROUND
THE SAME TIME WE WERE FORCED TO
ELIMINATE REDEVELOPMENT WHICH
GENERATED ONE BILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
RELYING UPON VOTER APPROVED
BONDS AND ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
ALLOCATIONS WILL NOT ALLOW US TO
BUILD THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
UNITS ON THE SCALE THAT WE NEED
TO SOLVE THE CRISIS. THIS LACK
OF INVESTMENT IS AN IS AN
ADEQUATE THIS LACK OF INVESTMENT
IN AN ADEQUATE SUPPLY OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING HAS HAD A
DIFFERENT IMPACT. ON OUR
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS. ALTHOUGH WE
HAVE INVESTED MORE RESPONSES
THAN EVER BEFORE AND HOUSING
OVER THE LAST THREE YEARS. WE
HAVE A LOT OF GROUND TO COVER UP
TO MAKE UP FOR THE DECADES AND
DECADES OF UNDER INVESTMENT. ACA
FOURTEEN THE HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR EVERYONE OR
THE HOPE ACT AS RECALLING IT
SETS ASIDE. 5% OF THE STATE'S
BUDGET EACH YEAR FOR THE NEXT
TEN YEARS TO FUND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CONSTRUCTION. PAY FOR
HOMELESSNESS HOUSING AND
SERVICES AND KERR AND CREATE NEW
HOMEOWNERS. FOR PERSPECTIVE THIS
YEAR'S REVENUE WAS TWO HUNDRED
BILLION. WHICH WOULD HAVE MEANT
TEN MILLION FOR THE HOPE ACT.
THE ADMINISTRATION WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO DEVELOP A TEN YEAR
INVESTMENT STRATEGY WITH
SPECIFIC METRICS AND MEASURABLE
OUTCOMES AND I WANT TO
UNDERSCORE THAT THE
ACCOUNTABILITY COMPONENTS OF
THIS ARE VERY CRITICAL SO WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT- ARE
VOTERS AND TAXPAYERS ARE GETTING
A RETURN ON THEIR INVESTMENT IN
THAT WE'RE ACTUALLY FIXING THIS
PROBLEM. THE LEGISLATURE WOULD
APPROVE EXPENDITURES EACH YEAR
AS PART OF THE BUDGET PROCESS.
EVERY OCTOBER THE ADMINISTRATION
WERE WOULD REPORT THE OUTCOMES
OF THE HOPE BACK TO SHOW HOW
MANY UNITS ARE BEING CONSTRUCTED
HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE BEING HOUSE
ETCETERA. IN OTHER WORDS THE
DIRECT IMPACTS OF THESE DOLLARS.
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT WHICH
IS OBVIOUSLY A CRITICAL
PROPOSITION FOR US HERE IN THE
STATE AS WELL AS THE RAINY DAY
FUND WOULD NOT BE IMPACTED BY
FUNDING DIRECTED TO THE HOPE ACT
. THE IDEA FOR THIS BILL CAME
OUT OF A HOUSING WORKING GROUP
MANY OF YOU PARTICIPATED IN
AROUND THIS PAST FALL. AND TOOK.
MANY HOSTED EVENTS AND WENT TO
DIFFERENT EVENTS AND WHERE WE
DISCUSS THE STATE'S AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CRISIS. REPEATEDLY AT
EACH STOP. AT ALMOST EVERY
SINGLE STOP. LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
CONSTITUENTS HOMELESSNESS
SERVICE PROVIDERS IN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPERS LAMENTED THE
LACK OF FUNDING TO BUILD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. AND TO
PREVENT AND END HOMELESSNESS.
THIS MEASURE IS BOLD. AND SOME
MAY RAISE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
EFFECT OF LOCKING IN FUNDING ON
FUTURE BUDGET YEARS. BUT WE DO
NOT HAVE A CHOICE AT THIS POINT
TO TRULY ADDRESS THE ROOT CAUSE
OF THE HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS WE'RE GOING TO NEED TO
SPEND THESE DOLLARS. FOR
MULTIPLE YEARS. THE HOPE ACT
REFLECTS WHAT WE ALL KNOW IS A
MORAL IMPERATIVE TO END
HOMELESSNESS AND TO GIVE
FAMILIES AN AFFORDABLE PLACE TO
LIVE. IN ADDITION I ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS TO MAKE
CLEAR THAT THE 5% SET ASIDE IS A
FLOOR AND NOT A CEILING. AND
CREATE A TRIGGER TO TURN OFF THE
ALLOCATION TO THE HOPE FUND IF
THE STATE IS IN A DEEP RECESSION
OR THE GOVERNOR DECLARES A MAN
MADE OR NATURAL DISASTER. I HAVE
TWO WITNESSES WITH ME HERE TO
TESTIFY JOINING BY PHONE WILL BE
WITH THE DENNIS. WHO WILL BE
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CORPORATION FOR SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING SPEAK UP. AND IN PERSON.
AND IN PERSON ROBERTO JIMENEZ
CEO OF MUTUAL HOUSING. MISTER
JIMENEZ GO HEAD. GOOD MORNING
I'M A BAPTIST MINISTER YOUR
MUTUAL HOUSING CALIFORNIA HERE
IN SACRAMENTO. WHETHER THE ZERO
NET ENERGY AFFORDABLE RENTAL
HOUSING FOR AGRICULTURAL WORKERS
IN WOODLAND THE FIRST Z. ANY
RENTAL HOUSING IN THE NATION OR
LGBT WELCOMING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IN SACRAMENTO MITCHELL
HOUSING IS DELIVERING HOUSING
SOME OF THE MOST VULNERABLE BE.
IN THE POPULATIONS AND
COMMUNITIES. HAVE A STATE
CALIFORNIA NOT ALLOCATED
RESOURCES TO THESE TWO PROJECTS.
THESE COMMUNITIES WITHOUT A BELT
. SADLY IT OFTEN TAKES UP TO
FIVE YEARS TO BUILD A HOUSING
COMMUNITY BECAUSE OF THE
SCARCITY OF DEDICATED FUNDING.
DESPITE THE LEGISLATURE'S
DEMONSTRATED COMMITMENT TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CALIFORNIA
CONTINUES TO FACE A SHORTFALL OF
OVER ONE MILLION AFFORDABLE
HOMES FOR THE STATE'S LOWEST
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS. AND MORE THAN
A HUNDRED AND SIXTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS
ON ANY GIVEN NIGHT. THE GOVERNOR
AND LOGISTICS LEGISLATURE HAVE
DEMONSTRATED THEIR COMMITMENT TO
ADDRESSING THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS CRISIS
TIME AND AGAIN. IN RECENT YEARS
BY USING BUDGET SURPLUSES. TO
SUPPORT SOME OF OUR STATE'S MOST
EFFECTIVE HOUSING PROGRAMS WITH
MUCH NEEDED ONE TIME INVESTMENTS. ACA FOURTEEN WILL BUILD ON
THESE EFFORTS AND PROVIDE A
PERMANENT ON FOR ITS SOURCE OF
FUNDING AT THE SCALE NEEDED TO
CLOSE OUR STATE SHAMEFUL GAPS
AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING. BY
DEDICATING 5% OF THE GENERAL
FUND FOR THE NEXT TEN YEARS TO
FIND SOLUTIONS TO END
HOMELESSNESS A BILL FOR A
HOUSING ACA FOURTEEN WILL
TRANSFORM OUR STATE'S APPROACH
TO ADDRESSING THE NEEDS OF OUR
MOST VULNERABLE RESIDENTS.
CONSISTENT PREDICTABLE
AVAILABILITY OF THESE FUNDING
SOURCES AS CRITICAL FOR MUTUAL
HOUSING IN ORGANIZATIONS LIKE
OURS TO BE ABLE TO PLAN AND
EFFICIENTLY DELIVER THIS DATA
HOUSING TO CALIFORNIANS MORE
QUICKLY. MUTUAL HOUSING IS READY
AND PREPARED TO DELIVER OVER A
THOUSAND UNITS OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING TO LOCAL MARKETS. LAND
IS AVAILABLE BUT THE BECAUSE THE
FINANCING IS SCARCE IT PROJECT
COULD TAKE UP TO FIVE YEARS TO
DELIVER. HOMELESSNESS M. AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS TOO
IMPORTANT. AND CALIFORNIANS NEED
HOUSING NOW. FOR THESE REASONS I
URGE YOUR SUPPORT TODAY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU KNOW WILL GO TO
THE PHONE LINE FOR LINDSAY
DENNIS ARE YOU THERE. I AM. GO
AHEAD WITH YOUR TESTIMONY ONE
QUICK SECOND. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TO YOU TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE C. A. FOURTEEN MY NAME IS
LINDSAY DENNIS AND THE C. S. H.
SPEAK UP ADVOCATE WITH LIVED
EXPERIENCE OF HOMELESSNESS AND
THE POLICY CHAIR FOR THE LIVED
EXPERTISE ADVISORY PANEL FOR
UNION STATION HOMELESS SERVICES
. GROWING UP MY FAMILY WASN'T
PERFECT IN FACT I STARTED
ATTENDING AA MEETINGS OF THE
TEENAGER BECAUSE OF MY DAD'S
ALCOHOLISM. BUT I ENDED UP USING
IN HIGH SCHOOL. I GOT SOBER AND
WENT TO UC SANTA CRUZ WHERE I
GRADUATED WITH A DEGREE IN
PSYCHOLOGY. BUT AFTER GRADUATION
I STARTED DRINKING AGAIN UNTIL I
WAS KICKED OUT OF MY LIVING
SITUATION FORCED TO MOVE BACKIN
WITH MY PARENTS. IT WAS HORRIBLE
I WAS HORRIBLE FOR MOST OF MY
TWENTIES I WAS THE ABSOLUTE
WORST ALCOHOLIC AND TRUST ME.
I'VE KNOWN A LOT OF ALCOHOLICS.
I REMEMBER BEING SUICIDAL
BECAUSE I NEVER FELT SO LOST
RESPECT OTHER HOPELESSNESS. WITH
NOTHING TO DO YOU KNOW WHERE TO
GO AND NO SENSE OF SAFETY I FELT
AFRAID CONSTANTLY AND BECOMING
HOMELESS HOMELESS WAS MORE THAN
I CAN HANDLE. I WAS IN AND OUT
OF HOSPITALS HOTELS REHAB SOBER
LIVING PLACES YOU NAME IT. AFTER
BEING HOSPITALIZED OR
INSTITUTIONALIZED SEVEN TIMES TO
DETOX OR BECAUSE OF ANOTHER
SUICIDE ATTEMPT I LEARNED THAT
MY DRINKING HELPED ME COPE WITH
UNDIAGNOSED BIPOLAR DISORDER. IN
TOTAL EXPERIENCE SEVEN CHAOTIC
YEARS WITHOUT THE HOMELESSNESS.
AT THE TIME IT TOOK BETWEEN WHEN
I MOVED BACK HOME WHEN I
RECEIVED MY MENTAL HEALTH
DIAGNOSIS. EVENTUALLY I FOUND
THE RIGHT MEDICATION. AND
RECEIVED SECTION EIGHT HOUSING.
PERMANENT HOUSING HAS CREATED.
FOR ME AND ALLOWED ME TO
MAINTAIN UP. FOR A DECADE. I'VE
BEEN LIVING IN MY CURRENT
APARTMENT FOR SIX YEARS AND I
HAVE A GREAT RELATIONSHIP WITH
MY MANAGER. I NO LONGER WONDER
WORLD SLEEP AT NIGHT. I FEEL
SAFE AND BELIEVE EVERYONE
DESERVES THAT SAME SAFETY AND
THE STABILITY OF THE OF A
PERMANENT HOME. THAT MEANS
PROVIDING THE RESOURCES
NECESSARY TO OUR IN HOUSE
NEIGHBORS TO ACCESS THE
PERMANENT HOME THEY CAN ALSO
THRIVE. I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR HER LEADERSHIP
AND COMMITMENT TO CHAMPIONING
THIS LEGISLATION. IF PASSED THIS
WITH COOLEY TRANSFORMER STATES
APPROACH IN ADDRESSING OUR
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS BY PROVIDING
THE ON GOING FUNDING WE FUNDING
WE DESPERATELY NEED. WITH THAT
SAID I URGE YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO YOU
TODAY. THANK YOU TO BOTH
WITNESSES FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
THIS MORNING NOW WE'RE GONNA GO
TO THE ROOM IF THERE ANYBODY IN
THE ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO COME
UP AND EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT.
FOR H. C. A. FOURTEEN. COME ON
UP TO THE MIKE. MICHAEL RATIGAN
ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS COUNTY SANTA
CLARENCE PORT THANK YOU.
JENNIFER AMENTO WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING CONSORTIUM IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. ON
YOUR LAWLER ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT
. MARINO MY IN HERE FOR MARK
SAVERS OF THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
PARTNERSHIP IN SUPPORT. MARCUS
ALL THE ON BEHALF OF HOUSING
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AND REPAIRS WE'VE
EXHAUSTED THAT LINE SO NOW WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO THE PHONE LINES
EIGHTEEN TATE OPERATOR DO WE
HAVE ANYBODY ON THE PHONE LINES
WHO WISHES TO CALL IN TO EXPRESS
THEIR SUPPORT FOR A C. FOURTEEN
. PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO TWO S.
EXPRESSED. LINE NUMBER THIRTY
FIVE. FOREIGN THEY WANT THEIR
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT
. LINE NUMBER. TWENTY EIGHT.
GOOD MORNING SHARON REPORT WITH
THE CORPORATION FOR SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING IN STRONG SUPPORT. MY
NUMBER FORTY NINE. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
PHILADELPHIA CRANKS CALLING ON
BEHALF OF SB AT HOME ACTION FUND
AND CALL HOME IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. LIE NUMBER FIFTY. YES
GOOD MORNING NICCOLO DELUCA
CALLING ON BEHALF OF OUR PROFIT
HOW THE DIFFERENT CALIFORNIA
OAKLAND MAYOR LIBBY SCHAAF AT
BERKELEY MAYOR JESSE AIRGAIN IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE
NUMBER TWENTY THREE. NUMBER
TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NO RESPONSE WILL MOVE ON TO LINE
NUMBER FIFTY TWO. NUMBER FIFTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS WILL BE AT THE
LEASH ON BEHALF OF THE CITY O
SANTA MONICA AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. LINE NUMBER THIRTY
SEVEN. FIFTY S. B. ON BEHALF OF
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN SUPPORT. LIE NUMBER
FIFTY ONE. THIS IS A SET OF ALL
WITH PATH PEOPLE ASSISTING THE
HOMELESS IN STRONG SUPPORT. LINE
NUMBER TWENTY SIX. THIS IS
MERION LAMB WITH THE H. HOUSING
IN STRONG SUPPORT. MY NUMBER
TWENTY NINE. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR EXACTLY WARM UP ON BEHALF
OF LA FAMILY HOUSING IN STRONG
SUPPORT. LINE TWENTY FIVE.
RECALL LIVABLE CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT LINE TWENTY FOUR. NINE TWENTY. YES HELLO YES
YOUR LINES OPEN. I'M SORRY MY
NAME IS FRANCESCA WANDER I AM A
VOTING CONSTITUENTS AND EMPLOYEE
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT I'M ALSO A
MEMBER OF INDIVISIBLE CALIFORNIA
STATE STRONG SACRAMENTO YOLO AND
SACRAMENTO AND SAN FRANCISCO I
CALLED IN FOR SUPPORT AS HE TOO
WAS NOT CALLED AND I'M ALSO
SUPPORTING THIS BILL AS WELL
PLEASE RECORD BOTH OF MY
SUPPORTS. FOR BOTH OF THESE
BILLS. THANK YOU LINE. ELEVEN MY
NUMBER ELEVEN. ALL ON LINE
THIRTY. MY NUMBER THIRTY YOUR
LINES OPEN. A RESPONSE WE HAVE
NO FURTHER IN Q. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND THEN- DOESN'T APPEAR
THAT WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. SO WE WILL GO TO THE
ROOM IS THERE ANYBODY IN THE
ROOM WHO IS IN OPPOSITION TO A
C. FOURTEEN. NOBODY SCRAMBLING
TO THE MIKE SO WE WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES ONCE AGAIN EIGHTEEN
T. OPERATOR IS THERE ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION WHO WISHES TO EXPRESS
THAT ON THE PHONE. IF YOU'D LIKE
TO OPPOSE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AND
JUST BE A MOMENT AS WE- GATHER
THE INFORMATION. PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO TO OPPOSE. AND WE'LL
GO TO LINE NUMBER FORTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE CHAVEZ
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF REALTORS WITH AN IMPOSING
LEFT ON MONDAY ADDITION ON
DETAIL I'LL BE ALSO WANTED TO
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT ON S. B. WE
WERE UNABLE TO GET INTO THE
PHONE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND
WE HAVE NO FURTHER IN Q. OKAY SO
WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS GO AHEAD
MR LEE. I JUST WANNA THANK THE
CHAIR FOR THIS BOLD INITIATIVE
AND IT REALLY IS TELLING THAT WE
DON'T DEDICATE MORE FUNDING THAT
HISTORY MARGINAL FUNDING TO ON
THE BOOKS CHRIS CRITICAL CRISES
WE HAVE IN CALIFORNIA JUST OF
COURSE HOUSING. TO REALLY
COMMEND YOU FOR PUTTING THE
FLOOR OF AT LEAST 5% OF FUNDING
TOWARDS THE BUILDING AT.
PRESERVATION FOR A HOUSING FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS REALLY
IMPORTANT- YOU KNOW JUST AS WE
HAD DONE S. C. A. TO JUST NOW TO
UNDO THE PAST OF PREVENTING
PUBLIC HOUSING AND PUBLICLY
DEVELOPED HOUSING- I WE HAD A
COUPLE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THIS
TOO BUT- I WANT TO ASK IF IT WAS
POSSIBLE TO AT LEAST INCLUDE THE
MENTION OF SOCIAL HOUSING. I
DON'T WANT A SITUATION WHICH
WERE A DECADE FROM NOW AND ALL
THE MONEY IS ONLY GOING TO
PRIVATE. CORPORATIONS ARE
PRIVATE DEVELOPERS ONLY WE ARE
IN A SCENARIO WE NEED ALL
SOLUTIONS ON THE TABLE AND
SOCIAL HOUSING AS WE WORKED ON
HIS NECK MESERVE ONE OF THEM I
JUST DON'T WANT THERE TO BE
EVER. A FUTURE SITUATION AND I'M
ACTING OF PRECAUTION WHERE THEY
INTERPRET IT AS A HOUSING IS NOT
PART OF THIS I KNOW OBVIOUSLY BY
THE MISSION OF WHAT'S ARE YOU
GOING FOR THAT SOCIAL AND SHOULD
BE INCLUDED IN IT BUT I JUST
WANT TO SEE IF YOU CAN INCLUDE.
THE MENTION OF IT JUST SO THAT
IS CRYSTAL CLEAR IN THE FUTURE
IS THAT SOMETHING YOU'RE
POSSIBLE TO DETERMINANTS SO-
WHEN I APPRECIATE THE ADVOCACY
ON SOCIAL HOUSING IN THE SOMEONE
WHO'S I CHAIR THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON SOCIAL HOUSING AND
HAVE COST THEIR PREVIOUS BILLS
WITH YOU AND- SUPPORTED- YOUR
SOCIAL THE BILL GETTING OUT OF
COMMITTEES. THIS YEAR I'M VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE CONCEPT- AND
THE CREATIVITY AROUND NEW IDEAS
TO TACKLE THE- HOUSING CRISIS
THAT WE ALL LIVE IN YOU KNOW
THIS BILL- DOESN'T PRESCRIBE
SPECIFICALLY HOW THE FUNDS WILL
BE STATE WILL BE SPENT. I MEAN
WE DID THAT WITH A LOT OF
INTENTIONALITY AROUND CREATING
FOR ULTIMATE FLEXIBILITY- YOU
KNOW WITH A BILL WE AND YOU KNOW
I'M POWER AND REQUIRE A BCS AGE
TO DEVELOP A TEN YEAR. FUNDING
STRATEGY AS WE INCH MARKS AND I
THINK THAT IS THE PLACE FOR
THOSE CONVERSATIONS TO HAPPEN IN
TERMS OF WHERE'S THE BEST PLACE
AND HOW CAN THESE. FUNDS TO BE
ALLOCATED AWAY THAT'S MOST
EFFECTIVE THAT THAT GETS SORT OF. R. O. Y. ON THE INVESTMENT-
AND SO- THOSE MATCH. I THINK OF
TO BE COULD. AND I AS WE YOU
KNOW IF YOUR BILLS TO MOVE FOR.
AND YOU KNOW- BE SIGNED INTO LAW
BY THE GOVERNOR. YOU KNOW IF
THAT BECOMES A MECHANISM BY
WHICH THERE IS- SORT OF MONEY
WELL SPENT ON THE ISSUE. I THINK
THAT WOULD CERTAINLY BE IN PLAY
IN THE CONTEXT OF THE STRATEGY-
THAT IS DEVELOPED BY THE AGENCY.
AND THEN REFLECTED IN THE
METRICS AND SO I WANT TO
PRESERVE FLEXIBILITY. FOR THAT
TOO- FOR B. S. B. C. S. H. TO.
BOTH CREATE THAT PLAN AS WELL AS
PROVIDE THE- ACCOUNTABILITY
REPORT BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE
SO THAT SHOULD YOUR BILL COME
INTO PLAY AND GET SIGNED INTO
LAW. THERE'S A PLACE FOR THOSE
DISCUSSIONS WITHIN THE CONTEXT
OF THAT. YEAH AND CERTAINLY I'M
NOT ASKING FOR ANY CERTAIN
PERCENTAGE OR MECHANISM TO BE
PRESCRIBED AS OF HOUSING OR ANY
OTHER MECHANISM IN THAT SENSE
JUST TO MAKE SURE IT IN THE
FUTURE WE'RE NOT. CONSTRAINED
WHERE IT'S ONLY TO PRIVATE
HOUSING ON PRIVATE ENTITIES
ONLY. THAT'S MY BIG. CONCERN
ABOUT THIS THIS THIS ISSUE. I'M
THERE AGAIN NOT ASKING FOR SOME
PROGRAMS LIKE AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS ASK FOR JUST THE
MENTION OF SOCIAL HOUSING P. AS-
IN IT'S MUCH EASIER FOR US TO
CHANGE OUR BILLS IN THE
CONSTITUTION AND HOPEFULLY THIS
WILL PASS THIS YEAR. WE'LL GET
IN THE CONSTITUTION BY DON'T
WANT TO STEP SITUATION WHICH WE
HAVE TO GO BACK AND- CLARIFY
WITH VOTERS SO. NO HAVE YOU
SUPPORTED TODAY BUT IS SOMETHING
I DO WANT TO SEE ON THE FLOOR.
OKAY THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE.
DOESN'T APPEAR THAT WE HAVE ANY
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THIS
WEEK JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. RIGHT WE NEED A
MOTION AND SECOND THAT MOTION MY
KALRA SECOND BY LEE CO AND CALL
THE ROLL. MOTION TO BE ADOPTED
AS AMENDED AND REFERRED TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN APPROPRIATIONS
WICKS. HI I SEYARTO. THERE ARE
NO CARILLO. COREY I GABRIEL. HI
GABRIEL I KALRA KALRA AYE KILEY
KILEY KNOW BENNETT LEE LEE I.
FIFTY FOUR FIVE. THAT MOTION IS
OUT FIVE ZERO THANK YOU IF YOU.
I THINK WE NEED- I DON'T SEE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENNETT BUT-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- GABRIELLE WOULD
LIKE TO ADD TO. LET'S DO SOME
ADD ONS HERE. WHEN. A LOT OF
YEAH WHAT DO S. S. C. A. TO. FOR
MR GABRIEL YEAH AND I SEE IT. S.
C. H. Q- ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL
. I. YOU SEND THEM THE SEVEN
ZERO BUT WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
MISTER BENNETT. CORRECTFOR BOTH
BILLS FOR BOTH OF US OKAY YEAH.
ON THE THING RIGHT. YEAH OKAY.
YEAH THE PROPOSAL WORKERS. I
DON'T KNOW I DON'T KNOW. IT YOUR
INBOX IS I EVEN GOING BACK. ON
RIGHT. MISTER BENNETT ON. ANY-
THE- SO HE SENATE BILLS YOUR TO
NOT WHO REMEMBERED OF THE- WORD. WE ARE NOT THE THEM. YEAH ARE
NOT THAT. REALLY WE'LL SEE WHERE
- IT IS NOT A PROBLEM YEAH.
REPORTER ANOTHER.
FIVE WE WILL OPEN THE WRONG.
ASSEMBLY BENNETT- ACA FOURTEEN
AND WHEN I. AND NESIUS A FEW
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENNETT I. OKAY
BOTH BILLS ARE OUT AND THIS
MEETING IS ADJOURNED AND THERE'S
MY GAVEL. DO A LEFT HANDED OKAY.